the american civil war i love it
yeah bro you ever go to the nashville
battlefield here dude we used to do when
i was growing up we could do cwr's all
the time man really yeah oh we'd be at
him man we got to be the uh we got to do
the drum a few times what else i got to
be like a soldier's cocwr constantly do
you really yeah i don't know because i
was in gettysburg i grew up right next
to gettysburg yeah dude the reenactments
were [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] we should
have [ __ ] won
now you guys you guys stunk dude
we [ __ ] you guys up when we took the
gloves off the north just rained down on
them dude but well you know where we
[ __ ] up is we kept a lot of the
brothers out of the fight yeah
obviously
obviously if we had a plan to get i
think it did you know get a little bit
more
gets a bit more urban yeah we kept it
way too i think honkied out yes
yeah towards the end the the union was
like
get the brothers in also yeah [ __ ]
started
got bad but you guys had a lot of uh
i don't know why you guys won i guess we
we probably had some disorganization i
bet and i think you guys the the south
was much better
the generals were better yeah it was
organized but like lee and [ __ ]
stonewall jackson and long street those
guys were beasts yeah that's why they
were even in the fight was because of
how good they were oh wow because the
union outnumbered them more and more
industry more guns but they just didn't
have that streets they didn't have that
uh they posted smarts they had [ __ ]
in general yeah allegedly i don't want
to besmirch these guys but i could say
probably maybe they had some real nerds
up there yeah i could see that they had
nerds they were all well they were all
west point guys but they were all
like uh like there's a guy named
mcclellan
oh yeah george yeah you just wouldn't
attack yeah they're like you gotta go
lincoln was like go dude people in the
woods
that's crazy
sherman and grant dude sherman came down
and gave you guys what for he got
[ __ ] lucky pull up a picture of
sherman on mr sherman the civil war was
the man
let's get a look at him
i have his picture hanging in my house
he really got sherman and grant
and custard
oh george custer yeah and he was the one
dating indians as well i think that's
the one with his arms cross crazy hair
a lot of diy man a lot of dating indians
yourself you know they had a lot of
those dudes out there
a lot of them you know dipping in the
corn meal if you don't think you are
brother bro what would you be doing
i mean just get done committing a huma
you just get done committing an atrocity
you're not going to want to have some
sex
yeah yeah
at this point you've done you're you're
done right you're done you've sold your
soul you are evil that's a good let's go
once you go evil then you're [ __ ]
then you're in evil it's like normally i
wouldn't just grab this lady yeah but
but i did just kill a family yeah you're
right damn it's time to go that's crazy
once you go full evil you're full evil i
didn't really i never really thought
about that
you know we had a guy that lived across
youth from us named brad and i think he
killed his mother
who was our
favorite lunch lady annie
dude and we loved her dude and she liked
her one of her hands shook her both of
them shook
and she would like get the food and it
was just your whole town
waiting for the food to get to your
plate it was like one of those guys that
used to drive the dynamite trucks back
in the day you know on the rocky roads
it was just unbelievable really and then
the grandson came like yeah he got sick
of it well he uh
i think they thought that if they killed
her if she was gonna get they were gonna
get the apartment
and they didn't get it no the landlord
kept it uh somebody else
was like that's not how this works dude
yeah dude just bad punches in [ __ ]
medieval times yeah it was just a lot of
kill him to be the heir to this
apartment yeah just bad organization man
but yeah dude i can't believe that the
civil war would have been insane
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one